alors la peinture augmenté parle de nous
je technologie cela
furent comme on augmente l'humain avec
les nouvelles technologies
je m'appelle à becca et vous l'aurez
compris je suis venu vous parler de
peinture et plus précisément de la
peinture augmenter la peinture augmentée
est un mouvement que j'initie à la
manière des courants picturaux que vous
connaissez certainement comme
l'impressionnisme ou le cubisme par
exemple mais avant cela j'aurais
souhaité savoir est-ce que parmi vous
des personnes ont pu voir l'exposition
sur léonard de vinci au louvre oui si
tel n'est pas le cas je vous invite à
aller voir l'exposition elle a encore
lieu quelques jours et en fait elle
rassemble une collection incroyable de
deux des skis ce de ses peintures et
aussi de dessins qu'il a réalisé avec
ses recherches scientifiques la pitoune
à echoes amène ta aller la peinture est
une chose mental nous révèle le maestro
au coeur de la renaissance
cela signifie que la peinture n'est de
l'ain team d'une réflexion d'une pensée
d'image et même des motions avant
d'apparaître sur la toile et d'être
révélé au public
mais alors vous me direz quel est le
lien entre la peinture et la science
dans le cadre de léonard de vinci
on comprend bien que les deux notions
sont liés mais si on y réfléchit
dès l'origine de la peinture la science
en est mêlé
ne serait ce que par la chimie par
exemple si on pense aux pigments noirs
aux pigments ocre rouge de l'art
pariétal et aussi on peut invoquer la
géométrie par exemple le cercle parfait
de giotto qu'il avait
créer enfin qu'il avait peint à la main
levée ou bien la perspective avec les la
formalisation d'alberti ou d'albrecht
dürer et plus récemment nous avons
également le bleu de yves klein qui est
ce bleu outremer que vous avez peut-être
à l'esprit
et qu'il a créé avec l'aide des douars
adam qui en fait vendait de la peinture
au peintre de montparnasse comme picasso
niki de saint phalle ou soulage et qui a
effectué une recherche chimique pour
pouvoir mettre en valeur ce bleu
outremer qui est très intense à l'aide
d'une résine synthétique qui s'appelle
l'art oddo passe et qui en séchant
permet enfin se rétracter permet donc au
bleu outremer de se révéler et du coup
cette formule a fait l'objet d'un dépôt
à l'inpi sous le nom de bleu icab est
alors l'idée ici n'est pas de lister
toutes les accointances qui peuvent
exister entre la peinture et la science
mais simplement de pointer le fait qu'il
existe une relation quasiment organique
entre les deux et parallèlement à la
peinture à la peinture pigmentaire on a
vu se développer une révolution avec
l'arrivée du numérique il y à quelques
décennies et avec ce que l'on appelle
les digital paintings donc les peintures
numériques qui sont obtenus à partir de
codes informatiques et de logiciels de
création de l'image et il existe
d'ailleurs des peintres pigmentaire qui
se sont qui s'adonne avec beaucoup
d'appétence à cette discipline et je
pense notamment à au peintre britannique
david hockney que vous connaissez
peut-être pour ses peintures sur les
piscines ou ou pour
ses paysages qui a été qui a eu
récemment une rétrospective au centre
pompidou il ya peut-être un ou deux et
il utilise par exemple l'application
brushes qui est une application qui lui
permet de peindre en reproduisant la
palette graphique et les outils du
peintre sur un ipad ou un iphone est ce
qui permet finalement aux peintres
aujourd'hui de pouvoir créer en étant
nomades puisqu'il n'a plus tout le
matériel à transporter avec lui et
aujourd'hui on va même beaucoup plus
loin en matière de 'digital painting
je pense notamment aux univers 2d
japonais de teamlab qui ont exposé aux
la grande halle de la villette ou ici
par exemple vous voyez extrait natural
qui est une oeuvre de miguel chevalier
qui a été exposé à artistes et robots au
grand palais est ce que l'on voit enfin
donc c'est ce sont des oeuvres qui sont
générative immersive et même interactive
pour le public est littéralement plonger
dans l'oeuvre et où une interaction peut
se faire avec
avec l'oeuvre justement est en fait ce
qu'il faut retenir de tout ça c'est à
partir du moment où des technologies
vont apparaître
l'artiste va invariablement cherché à
s'en emparer pour créer ou bien même à
les détourner
alors qu'est ce que la peinture augmenté
avant tout je dirais que la peinture
augmenté c'est une hybridation du
pigment et du pixel si je vous dis qr
codes réalité augmentée réalité
virtuelle mapping smart pigmentent ou
même intelligence artificielle
ce sont des termes que vous connaissez
probablement certains mieux que d'autres
alors je vais quand même rappeler un
petit peu ces notions là le qr code est
né dans les années 90 2000 il s'agit
d'un quart et pixellisée quand vous
allez le scanner il va révéler une image
ou bien un texte ou un son la réalité
augmentée c'est un petit peu le même
principe en fait
avec un logiciel vous allez pouvoir avec
un appareil mobile scanner par exemple
une toile dans mon cas et ça va révéler
un contenu qui va être par exemple une
vidéo ou même du son ensuite on à la
réalité virtuelle qui nécessite un
outillage et qui est très à la mode
actuellement est en fait il faut avoir
un casque et des outils technologiques
qui permettent aux peintres de pouvoir
effectuer des gestes traditionnels mais
deux pintes en 3d virtuellement en 3d en
tout cas le mapping en fait c'est une
projection sur des éléments
d'architecturé ou bien même sur une
projection vidéo pardon ou bien même sur
une toile et l'intelligence artificielle
alors plus spécifiquement le dip
learning serait une technologie qui
reproduirait le le le cerveau humain est
en 2014
un ingénieur de chez google a créé un
algorithme qui permet de générer des
images fictive à partir d' images
existantes sens là sans l'aide d'un
humain et c'est notamment avec cette
technologie que une équipe de microsoft
a pu créer the next rembrandt que vous
voyez là qui en fait un rembrandt fier
fictif obtenu à partir d'une database
d'une base de données de portraits
que rembrandt avait effectué alors si je
vous parle de toutes ces technologies
c'est parce que ce sont des technologies
que moi même je vais utiliser dans la
peinture en sachant que j'ai toujours
une base pigmentaire je vais allez
augmenter cette base pigmentaire en
infusant finalement de la technologie et
du pixel dans le pigment l'idée c'est de
pouvoir avoir une contemplation comme
vous avez une une contemplation
quand vous allez visiter un musée ou une
galerie d'art mais aussi finalement de
pouvoir expérimenter la peinture en en
l'activant par exemple c'est le cas de
la réalité augmentée que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure et peut-être même en allant la
compléter alors cela permet de pouvoir
stimule et d'autre sens que la vue est
finalement peut-être de réveiller
d'autres émotions qui sont liés à
d'autres sens donc ça peut être louis ou
l'odorat ou où tout ça en même temps et
peut-être que ces nouvelles émotions
peuvent aussi amener à un nouveau type
de réflexion en tout cas c'est les
recherches que je mène actuellement
et là je vous présente earth
alors c'est une peinture que j'ai
réalisé à partir de pigments
traditionnel de bombes aérosols et de
matières végétales mais aussi je parlais
du smart pigmentent alors là il y en a
je vais vous expliquer aussi comme enjeu
l'utilisent et là on est véritablement
dans ce que j'appelle une expérience
picturale et c'est une notion qui est
très importante pour moi parce que je
vais inviter le public à être soit dans
la contemplation et avoir cette toile et
c'est tout ou bien finalement 2-2
d'avoir une interaction même physique
avec la toile puisque il va pouvoir par
le smart pigman justement aimante et des
éléments pollution comme vous pouvez le
voir à droite
donc on voit un mégot par exemple ou
bien de la matière plastique et
finalement quand on entend le discours
scientifique on a peut-être parfois du
mal à se figurer
quel est notre empreinte carbone par
exemple
d'ailleurs pour pour ce travail et là
j'ai aussi créé enfin j'ai essayé de
reculer de recréer pardon le l'odeur de
la pollution pour qu'on soit aussi
envahi à ce niveau là et finalement ça
nous permet peut-être d'une manière
ludique de réfléchir à notre impact
voilà de mener une réflexion sur
l'environnement
et puis vous avez une partie en réalité
augmentée c'est à dire que quand vous
scannez la peinture un message vidéo
passe voilà ça c'est une illustration du
travail que je peux effectuer ensuite je
vais vous parler de du lien que je peux
créer entre la peinture et les sciences
donc vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
nous sommes à l'aube d'une révolution du
vivant et notamment à travers des
nouvelles technologies que l'on appelle
les ntic qui sont les nanotechnologies
biotechnologies l'informatique et les
sciences cognitives et en fait c'est
c'est ces technologies et notamment
chris père cazeneuve dont vous avez
peut-être entendu parler mais que je
je verrai je vais m'en rappeler
rapidement la notion donc il s'agit en
fait du séquençage de l'adn
c'est une technologie qui permet
notamment de pouvoir réparer des gènes
chez l'humain notamment dans le cas de
maladies héréditaires et c'est donc
c'est une c'est une technologie qui va
vraiment permettre de
une grande avancée en matière de
thérapie génique entre autres ensuite on
à l'interface cerveau machine alors il
s'agit de relier un ordinateur à un
cerveau humain et comme pour la
technologie précédente
c'est une technologie qui peut aider
l'humain dans sa santé notamment enfin
je peux donner un exemple par exemple et
les personnes qui souffrent de handicap
pourrait être relié à un exosquelette
pour le le mouvoir et donc regagné 1 un
peu d'autonomie est en fait tout ça
serait génial
s'il n'y avait pas le revers de la
médaille c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on
a aussi d'aider des laboratoires ou même
des entreprises qui font des recherches
on peut se poser la question pourquoi
ces recherches pensa notamment pour
triste perd 15 9 le où je pense à il ya
un laboratoire qui est en train
notamment de rechercher le gène de la
douance donc le gène du génie mais
finalement pourquoi faire pour créer une
arme et jenny est ce que c'est ce qu'on
veut de la technologie c'est c'est
pareil pour l'interface cerveau machine
on sait qu'il ya une start up entre
autres qui essayent de relier le cerveau
au cloud
mais que se passerait-il si un virus
informatique passé par là par exemple ou
bien si quelqu'un une personne
malveillante souhaitait en prendre le
contrôle
et c'est pareil pour les puces rfid que
des personnes portent aujourd'hui dans
le monde volontairement sous leur peau
alors c'est absolument génial parce que
ça facilite la vie des gens ça permet
d'ouvrir un ascenseur d'allumer un
ordinateur ou même de payer à la
comptine mais que se passe-t-il si
finalement tout votre intimité est entre
de mauvaises mains donc voilà c'est
toute la panoplie de questions que je
peux
me poser et du coup je me demande aussi
si en augmentant en enrichissant sans
cesse l'humain est ce qu'on finit pas
par pouvoir perdre ce qu'on appelle
justement ce qui nous caractérise en
tant qu'être humain et finalement c'est
un petit peu la même chose pour la
peinture
est-ce qu'à force de l'enrichir de
l'augmenter technologiquement ça reste
ou non de la peinture
voilà donc toutes ces questions je les
partage avec vous ce soir et sans être
technophiles ni technophobes je vous
invite finalement à réfléchir à ce qu'on
veut faire de toutes ces technologies à
penser ce qui est technology for good
aussi pour le bien de l'humanité et pas
uniquement parce que tout à l'heure je
vous parlais de la renaissance avec
léonard de vinci et à l'époque de la
renaissance
l'humain est au centre des réflexions et
des préoccupations
aujourd'hui je me dis que peut-être ce
type de peinture et alors là je fais une
parenthèse pour pour c'est ce que vous
voyez derrière moi c'est une simulation
de
da dn craquer d'une hybridation de ce
que pourrait faire un christ perd 15 9
si la technologie permettait d'hybrider
l'adn d'un humain avec l'adn
d'animaux en l'occurrence ici c'est avec
une méduse phosphorescentes et avec un
caméléon
et puis vous avez un autre exemple là ce
serait si on pouvait par exemple hybride
et l'humain avec le végétal et puis là
vous avez ce que ça pourrait donner si
on hybride l humain avec de la
technologie
donc voilà toutes ces questions m'invite
à réfléchir autour de cette notion
justement de
enfin philosophique de réflexion qui à
l'époque de la renaissance comme je le
disais était une réflexion autour des
questions liées à l'humain et
aujourd'hui je me demande finalement si
mes recherches ne mène pas vers une
forme de nouvelle renaissance ou une
poste renaissance où ce ne serait plus
l'humain qui serait au centre de nos
préoccupations mais tout le vivant
l'environnement les animaux etc
et voilà je vous laisse sur cette
réflexion je vous remercie de m'avoir
écouté
si ce travail vous intéresse vous pouvez
le suivre sur les réseaux sociaux ou
bien sur mon site internet
bonne soirée merci au revoir